welcome back well most kids are asking
for at least one device this holiday
season but how do you know which one to
get choosing the right age-appropriate
device for your children in the sea of
options can be overwhelming so we search
for some help here's more
mom and lifestyle Guru Bobby Thomas says
the right device for your kid is out
there she suggests starting with Amazon
there's a variety of content with the
Fire tablet there is the love of reading
it's distraction free on the Kindle
they're not going to games or apps and
the Alexa enabled Echo devices are
wonderful for curiosity and that sort of
you know Independence to just learn more
Thomas also has some advice for parents
worried about screen time this holiday
season my advice look for devices that
are designed with kids in mind and in
fact this season some of the hottest
devices are from Amazon one of the
reasons I really love the suite of
products they offer for kids is because
it comes with an award-winning parental
dashboard this was foolproof it was so
easy for me to understand and simple for
more information visit amazon.com for
kids
you do got to be careful um when giving
your old iPhones maybe to your kids
because A girlfriend of mine she gave
her son her old iPhone didn't it wasn't
connected to any service or anything you
can still call 9-1-1 oh and the kid
called 9-1-1 they were like is
everything okay she's like oh my gosh I
had no idea so just a little word of
warning for you yeah probably a good
safety feature to have but also good to
know say your kids don't start pushing
but we'll continue